10-5-3. RYAN GETZLAFPLAY
UNIT.
PUCK MANEUVE
AND LOOK LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR TOTOPOINT SWING.
TANNER JEANNOT LOOKING UP THE
ICE FOR YAKOV TRENIN. RYAN
JOHANSEN.
1-0, NASHVILLE.
ON TRACK.TO THE NECK.
GETS A BYE JUUSE SAROS.
WHAT A SAVE!   RIDING THROUGH
TRAFFIC.
HE USJOSI.
.POINT BLANK.
A REBOUND STOP AS WELL.
HE GETS UP.
JOHN GIBSON MAKES A HECK OF A
SAME.
HE GETS IT OVER THE PAD. INJURE
AND A   FOR
YOU.
MET DUCHENE SPITTING UP.
HE STILL SUPPORT.
CENTERING PASS.
ONE-TIMER STOP
COUSINS HIT THE CROSSBAR.E FORE
WIN BATTLES.
TOMASINO BEHIND THE NET.
NOVAK WORKING ON THE WALL.
SHOT.
GOOD CHECKED BY THE DUCKS.
HE POWERS TO  THE NET.
THE REBOUND CLEARED BUT
OUT HIGH.
A GREAT SET BY TRAN A,  DENIES
MATT
>> Willy: MIKAEL GRANLUND WITH
TIME TICKING DOWN ,LASER
BEAM THROUGH TRAFFIC OVER THE
SHOULDERSECOND .
SO, NA
GRENOLA LOOKING FOR MATT
DUCHENE.
BEHIND THE NET.
YES TO SIMON DOWN.
>> Chris: I DANTE'T KNOW WHAT
THIS  GETS.
IT LOOK
BUT IT UP.
OFF ROMAN JOSI.
OFF FABBRO .
>> Chris: ONE, A A
SISSONS AND HIS CREW
INCREDIBLE INDIVIDUAL. HE IS JU
BOARDS.
YAKOV TRENIN
RAKELL TO THE NINE .
RIGHT HERE, RAKELL PARSE IT TO
THE NET.
IT HIT THE POST!
REBOUND IN FRONT.
AND 21
AND FILL UP  GRANLUND.
GRAY NIGHT WITH SPEED.
AND WITH YOU.
HE HAD A CHANCE AT IT.
ALMOST, FROM POINT BLANK RANGE
LEAVES BEHIND THE NET.
RAKELL.
BACKHAND FEED.
THEY WORK RIGHT THERE
. JUUSE SAROS SPRAWLING TRYING
TO BLOCK THAT.